I'm starting with you uh you've been
you've worked uh you've been working on
the Resident Evil franchise at Capcom
for a very long time what do you think
it is about this world and these
characters that has resonated with so
many people around the world for so long
um
it's very much thanks to your fan base
passion that made us continue this
franchise yeah foreign
so it's been almost like three decades
and it's thanks to the fans loving all
the characters one of the things though
you have a great responsibility to make
sure that the franchise doesn't go off
the rails can you talk about the the
responsibility you feel to you know
maintain the quality and to take care of
these characters
foreign
so the game series been continuing long
but also the game system's been
advancing so much so the Techno
technique technology has been advancing
and they had to update all the time but
while updating
um the capcom's been trying to
renovate and innovate things and to
continue doing the the franchise now uh
forget what he said but
but uh in in any case
um
[Laughter]
so the character's been aging too but uh
you guys are like aging together and
it's it's you know the franchise has
been continuing very long uh sorry it's
not a good translation
I'm curious can you talk a little bit
about how you came up with the story and
setting for this film and whose decision
was it to include all the characters
because you you include so many key
characters from the franchise first I
can't speak English sorry
but I have a
recent evil and this game fans thank you
today a question answer
Japanese
[Laughter]
so it's the the series has been uh like
sustained so long and then we wanted to
have like a big climax now here with you
co-wrote the last film of I believe
Vendetta what did you learn writing that
that you wanted to apply to this one
yeah
[Music]
didn't have enough jokes so he increased
more jokes but I think it was not enough
even this one so he wants to do more
next time so foreign
[Laughter]
what do you love about actually the
world of Resident Evil and being able to
voice this character because as I said
earlier this is a franchise it means so
much to so many people I mean I grew up
with Resident Evil I remember coming
home from high school and playing the
first one for the PlayStation with a
friend's house and so being being a
person that loved each of these games
and then to be able to take on the
mantle of Leon S Kennedy was a huge
honor and and to work with so many
wonderful people to bring these stories
to life and to bring my personal flavor
while playing homage to what came before
me has been just something that I will
carry with me the rest of my life
um so it means a lot to me and I'm
excited to see where it goes from here
I'm excited to see all the classic
people that continue to bring the story
to life all the new voices that come up
to bring it to life the people that I
have the honor to pass the torch on to
uh all in all I'm very thankful and very
grateful to have been a part of this so
it means a lot to me Nicole same thing
for you what does it mean to be part of
this world that means so much to so many
people and being able to voice Jill uh I
mean it's an absolute unbelievable
pleasure it's a dream come true and a
joy um such an iconic character for so
long
um so really same getting to kind of
Step into the shoes of someone that's
been portrayed for so many years and
kind of bring myself and my iteration
with the trust of an amazing team that
brings it to life it's it's just truly a
pleasure and the fans are unreal they're
just amazing and the the number of
stories that I've I've heard from multi
multi-generational fans
um of like what these characters mean to
them is so special I get access to
stories and people in a way that I never
thought you know you kind of do the work
and then it comes back to you in ways
that are really unexpected and beautiful
so I'm very grateful internationally too
yes there are a few franchises I've been
a part of that have such a worldwide
reach as Resident Evil people from all
over the world engage with this story in
these characters it's incredible
another question for the two of you um
what do you think would surprise
Resident Evil fans to learn about the
voice recording of a Resident Evil movie
like this
what you got what'll surprise you I'm
curious
um I mean I don't know how surprising
this would be but we have a lot of fun
and especially when you script jokes
into it but we make a lot of jokes as
well and I think anytime you're working
in horror genre as well people that are
doing really scary stuff tend to have
the most fun on set because the more
intense it ends up looking in the end
the more ridiculous it looks when we
shoot it or when we record it because
we're you know either screaming in a
soundproof room or wearing ridiculous
suits or something so they they really
do all of the magic we just get to show
up and have fun
there's definitely a lot of silly
bloopers that uh we get to experience in
the booth and I guess one thing you
might find interesting if you aren't
aware a lot of the combat scenes in here
we're making every grunt every impact
sound every pain reaction which is a
very physically taxing experience you
may not understand so many of us are
very sweaty very exhausted and very
terrifying people to be around by the
time you finish a lot of these recording
sessions
are we good are we done are we finished
the breathing the breathing no one
realizes like every time just like
checking out all the things in every
room we sat there and breathed for
minutes on end
foreign
what's funny is uh recording those
efforts um I don't think people realize
do you do they make you wait till the
end of the day to do those to do those
efforts or is it first thing in the
morning
uh I think it depends on how big the egg
is really depends I
want to do it first you want to do it
later I'm like how hard do we have to
die or fall or shoot or something yeah
if it's screaming on fire for three
minutes
um yeah the gentle breathing or holding
your breath we can do that first yeah
whatever we'll start with that one
that'd be easy
uh itro um this is a question for you
um one of the things about this is you
get to play with all these characters
that mean so much to so many people
um what were the challenges during the
production of making sure everyone had
screen time and making sure it would
honor the franchise
foreign
of course the five characters all get
together and then he wanted to make sure
that because each character have each
fan base so the each fan got to sort of
enjoy this movie so he he made sure that
each character stands out one of the
things about the Resident Evil franchise
is people love the creatures and the
monsters so um how did you come up with
the creatures for this film and
specifically without spoilers in the
third act there is a big monster so talk
a little bit about coming up with uh
with with this is
foreign
and the kind of creepy skin like the the
shark but then uh the size was something
that they were struggling and like
looking into because the whole set of
that Armory like uh you know you have to
decide the size of the Armory and you
have to decide how these ceilings falls
off that kind of stuff so the sizes were
like changing all the time and it became
kind of bigger than expected actually
I'm going to ask you a follow-up there's
always a shot or number two or a
sequence the directors I've heard go
back to repeatedly because they're just
not a hundred percent happy which was
the scene or sequence that you spent
extra time on because you wanted it to
be perfect
I know
motion capture three
seasons
foreign
so the thing is um he's a really live
action director and this is on the
second time to do CG animates since
infinite Darkness but the way he wants
to work with is the motion capture
actors and the
um the crew kind of like he wants to
build the whole movie together and work
together to build certain scenes so
um I he he wants to say that probably it
it worked well with the Ensemble sort of
efforts
the two difficult things to do in CGI
one is somebody eating something that
seems very difficult and the other thing
is whatever with water inside water that
kind of stuff and so there he was told
not to do that and but he saw it we did
it descriptions
I know
this producers
so he was first listening to the
producer and not spending the money and
not doing the water scene but actually
the the Arts directors and the staff
really wanted to do so they they decided
to go for it and had to convince the
producer which is me to do it
so it worked well yes I have a question
for you then what is it like when uh
when filmmakers come to you with
something like that when you know this
is going to cost money to do because
this you know what is that like what is
that conversation am I supposed to
comment that
I'm bringing you in I mean I generally
say yes but uh in general as long as I'm
able to convince my big boss yes yeah
that's that's all
sure this is a question for everyone who
wants to answer uh there have been many
Resident Evil games uh do you which is
your personal favorite and why and this
is whoever wants to answer yes
foreign
[Laughter]
this is
I guess
[Laughter]
doesn't want to comment because he makes
all of them
finished re4 remake and it was amazing
it was really really good I really
enjoyed it but I have to say I'm pretty
biased to the ones that I'm in
that makes sense
I mean the original four for the
GameCube was the one that kind of really
solidified
the entire franchise for me I love them
all but at four I was like this is
really a movement in gaming and then the
Remake even just elevated even further
so yeah kind of kind of with you on that
what what do you think it is though that
pulls so many people in because it's so
popular and it's been so popular for so
long I think it's a testament to the
fact that it it kind of adjusted the
mood of what was expected of the classic
and the survival horror genre
um it really kind of paid a deeper
attention to the solitary storytelling
of a character in a uh a place they're
unfamiliar with with a number of unique
twists on the classic kind of virus
zombie storytelling and uh some great
gameplay mechanics like it just it
really brought a lot of things that were
fresh to a genre that everyone was kind
of contemplating how it was going to
stay unique and fresh and then the uh
the Remake just continued to elevate it
on every level from cinematics to
improved gameplay to treating the
storytelling with so much respect and
and yeah I can go on for a while but
yeah I think those are a handful of the
examples
I'm not sure if you will answer this or
what you can say but there's a lot of
Resident Evil fans in this audience uh
what can you tease besides this movie
for the future of Resident Evil whether
it be in TV movies video games what
would you like to tease
but
he's gonna ask us something
um
so the the franchise is going to have
the 30th birthday probably like in 26th
right
yeah so 30 years yeah so uh basically
he's planning a lot of stuff and but uh
you have to like look forward to it
within a few years time frame but uh
that's all he can say
I think that's a very nice tease to let
people know that you guys are planning
some cool stuff for the 30th anniversary
[Laughter]
he's planning whatever that's going to
please you
[Laughter]
thank you for indulging that uh I want
to make sure if there's anyone in the
audience who has a question that um they
can ask or I can continue
um does anyone have any questions
I see a hand right there
uh my question is for Mr Mercer so an
interview you said you were incredibly
excited
um and there was the the in your career
when you got cast Frozen number six to
play Leon coming back later after the
explosion of critical role and getting
into all these other characters over the
years that so many people love what
challenges of any did you face were
prizing that wall and getting back into
this character
that's a good question
um
Leon in stepping into the role of Leon
really was a shift in trajectory for my
career I think it brought
um not just like an attention to me as a
performer but it gave me an opportunity
to be part of something that was very
important to me as a gamer as a person
that loves these stories in these games
so all these years it's been a wonderful
experience to step into these shoes
every chance I have
um as the years have gone on and other
projects have grown and become their own
unique behemoths yeah
um this this series and this character
has always been something very very uh
dear to me and uh to be perfectly honest
when uh I you know passed the torch on
to Nick and watch the remakes and just
become something even more incredible as
it goes on I never expected to come back
I thought that was over and trying not
to be emotional
um I was very uh surprised and excited
at the opportunity to step back into
these shoes uh another time and so uh I
say the challenges for me are ensuring
that I am both playing respect and
homage to what I've had the opportunity
to present before to the people that
came before me and to those who have
come after me and just kind of you know
enjoy the time that I have with this to
bring whatever our
flavor I can to this and and specific
kind of Joy I hope people can take out
of this and to have the opportunity to
work with so many wonderful people both
on the production side on the cast and
everything Beyond so uh the challenge is
just ensuring that I can enjoy the
moment as much as I can does anyone else
have any questions or would you like me
to continue I think I see a hand over
there
targets of how is it for you to come and
ask Jill and Resident Evil 3 but to come
back in Jedi which is so far removed
from that storyline said we haven't seen
her since Resident Evil 5 and caught up
with it for a housing for you to be in
such a pivotal moment for Joel's journey
and then to come back and had so much
character so much Advent history that's
happened between now and then for you to
you know show everyone again after so
long yeah thanks uh it's a great
question and honestly so special and
very very cool because obviously when
I'm stepping into re3 she's already got
PTSD and struggling from the trauma from
the Mansion incident and and her
training and everything that came before
but she's still relatively in the
beginning of her journey in so many ways
so you know jumping into that was its
own fun challenge so then getting to
come see her almost present day so much
later after all of the other stuff that
she's been through with Wesker and the
mind control and and everything else it
it was a unique challenge but it really
was kind of like the actor's journey of
like yeah just doing my research like
where are we at what's happened what
would still be influencing her at this
moment and then obviously I'm just
surrounded by a team that is incredibly
supportive to be like this this detail
and so kind of culminating all of those
things and going okay great well given
everything that she's been through and
what she's looking at this story in so
many ways is looking at Jill still
coping with drama well not well up for
you to decide but it's really beautiful
to watch her kind of reintegrate with
this team so it was really special
because I got to come to this with even
more history and more depth of
everything that this character has been
through throughout her entire
existence so that's so special for me I
have a question for the filmmakers if I
can just do something real quick one of
the things I'm curious about for the
Resident Evil franchise in a movie like
this in America oftentimes there's so
many committees that are involved in
making this decisions for an IP that's
incredibly popular so I'm just curious
like for you guys what is it like behind
the scenes in terms of when you're
writing a screenplay how many people do
you have to appeal like appease
um you know like what is it like behind
the scenes and how much Freedom do you
have to you know do what you want to do
um if I can ask this
it's a difficult question
for him and me too
much
so the answer is uh you know it's a big
struggle of course and there's a lot of
things to do but this time I think we
could do a great job 100 actually to to
like have everybody agree and then
please you guys so
um he didn't mention how many people but
we we everyone we was agreeing that
foreign
they could do their own thing and and
didn't really control but uh he's asking
whether it was true or not
talk
producers
[Laughter]
he says the producers were saying all
the time okay brought a lot of money and
uh and was having fun with hasmism
that's what she says
I guess I have to change my you know
mindset
um
there's a sort of handbook with all
these like timing and what's happened
like a long history of Resident Evil so
they were like Consulting that with
Capcom so it was kind of like actually
easy to make this legitimately sort of
Cannon to the the game so because there
was a sort of a long how do you call it
the like a Bible Bible yeah
[Music]
that everybody wanted to please the fan
base so there wasn't really a constraint
in that case it just everybody knew
where to look for and what to go for
yeah I wasn't trying to rock the boat I
was just curious what it's like behind
the scenes
I wasn't trying to you know you know
what I mean
um so listen I think oh um I think we're
basically out of time but can we do one
more
uh uh do you have a question
yeah we have time let's do it
um I've got a question for all of you
because you've all got experience in
entertainment business
um I'd love to see your thoughts in
General on adaptations because there's a
lot of that going around and
um specifically what interests me is
like from one medium to the other
because your perspective and your focus
is changing and I was wondering if in
general any of you have any thoughts and
what kind of decisions go into changing
from one medium to the other this so
specifically video game uh first person
perspective but unfocused because you
can go anywhere to a film where it's uh
second person because the audience is
second person but
um forced perspective or your your
railroading along
um the story and any thoughts or uh
decisions that are interesting that you
have to make
um in that translation
good question thank you
[Music]
it's such a difficult question that it's
gonna take days to actually explain
an art form because
that goes back to what is the movie
actually
[Laughter]
come on
SO game is important that you actually
experience with your yourself
whereas movie is receiving a lot of
emotional things and emotional
information that you get in the emotion
it's still experienced but it's a
different way it's more receptive now uh
if we start talking about you know like
how you can transform each other that's
a long story but and then again this
we're trying to have these two media
sort of like approach that's what I
think is what she said
it is foreign
manga it's kind of a like one personal
experience whereas movie like you
gathered here it's kind of a sharing
experience and you think it's something
that is you know like everybody can
share your gamer but you watch this
movie but after enjoying this movie
together then you can actually go back
to the game yourself but it's more of a
sharing experience that's what he thinks
it is and on that note I'm going to say
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for attending our screening tonight and
thank you a round of applause for all
the people here that worked on Resident
Evil death Island and uh if you're on
social media uh and you enjoyed the
movie uh please uh say something